i'm going to anally rape bobby lee
what clip clip it clip it james
click and send it to bobby i don't want
it i will do that
dude bobby i probably won't show up
watch a little movie called deliverance
and you're going to see what's about to
happen to you
can you can you have your wife kick
their ass because they made me look like
a [ __ ] too honestly
what they do they do to nick i i [ __ ]
up and i booked stevie weeby on this
podcast for the culture corner
uh we're gonna treat them nice and get
some info out of them maybe
attack bad friends and uh we canceled or
we moved up the show last week from
monday to tuesday and i
forgot to call stevie and he showed up
at this
at the studio and i was at home no one
was here and he cried i guess he didn't
have a ride he hitched a ride
i found out because bobby text me was
like dude
what the [ __ ] i was like i have nothing
to do with it
uh i fell on the sword though but uh
yeah they kind of gave me they said
hello hey what's up dude hey what's
going on
hey man you're on uh you're on the show
we're recording you i just want to let
you know upfront be candid with you but
i got to tell you bud
it is not going good the first 15
minutes bobby has been just losing his
mind
he's been yelling because something
about his brother and you guys didn't
get him on the show and he's
freaking the [ __ ] out right now he's mad
what happened
man i uh i can ask you what can i ask
you a question hold on
okay why do you
do you disrespect me and my family
no i honestly like when you look at
other comedians
you you probably respect them and you
respect their time
am i is it because i'm not funny to you
or it's because i don't have that
the respect in the comedy community or i
don't know what the [ __ ] the deal is
bro
that's my brother bro i know
he doesn't have money he [ __ ] got his
way out there
and he we are no no no no no he's not
about money he doesn't want his money
dude
when he knocked on that door and you
guys
weren't there my brother [ __ ] cried
bro
it's disrespectful
and it's like i'm just asking you is it
did i do anything
personally to you to hurt you in any
kind of way because it just seems like a
[ __ ]
slam on me my career
cry tears right now too dude it's
disrespectful bro
so can you explain yourself
there's no explanation except that i
[ __ ] up see when brendan had nothing
to do with it
i booked him we moved the show up
because theo didn't come
back from nashville i could not feel
worse
this is not that ingest at all what
about a field what about
this what about a phone call
[Laughter]
and uh yeah they eventually were like
we're just kidding but uh i think bobby
is actually pretty pissed that
he was a little pissed yeah he
definitely wait so what what happened
though you booked his brother
yeah bob bobby lee's brother on the
podcast what is
i've never heard of them either there's
another body and
nick gnome he can come on i i don't i
don't know who he is yeah but the thing
is
here's my thing bobby your brother had
taken uber here
for he didn't have money to get how do
you not
get your brother a car how do you not
take your brother dude i actually blame
this on bobby
i would say i agree with you you know
what it's bobby's fault
for putting him in this situation
knowing the type of shenanigans that
podcasts go up to
so bobby i say to you you're
disrespectful to your brother and you
don't respect him and his podcast
yeah that's what i say and i feel like
your brother because i have your pubes
in my mouth